如內心有夢 便全力追蹤
不須計那天才可終
好比天空疾勁野風
撞到人了
撞到人喇
過去看一下
過去睇下
阿伯 撞哪了
阿伯 你撞到邊度啊
好痛
好痛啊
哪裡痛
邊度痛啊
不知道 哪裡都痛
唔知呢 度度都痛囉
我扶你起來
我扶你起身
動不了
郁唔到啊
是不是撞車黨啊 真的假的
係咪撞車黨啊 真定假的㗎
喂 警察啊 這裡有車禍
喂 999啊 呢度撞左車
我現在在大鵬
我而家係大鵬
阿伯 我都是個演員
阿伯 我都係個演員嚟嘅
以撞車黨來說痛的表達是非常重要的
撞車黨嚟講呢 痛嘅表達係非常之咁重要嘅
我都不覺得你痛 哪有說服力呢
我都唔覺得你痛 咁邊度有說服力呢
哎呀
略嫌有點隨便
略嫌求其啊
你現在是給車撞了 你就哎呀一聲
你依家比車撞呀 你哎呀咁
這怎可過關呢
點過到骨啊
你都演不到位觀眾沒法同情你
你係都唔交足戲 啲觀眾好難同情你㗎喎
真的好痛
真係好痛
不要嚇我吧 大哥
唔好嚇我啦 哥哥
這麼差怎謀生 認真點
搵食㗎喎 認真啲啊
你看我
你睇我
我暈了
我暈喇
你又做什麼 大哥 不要自作聰明
你又做咩呀 哥哥 唔好叻唔切啦
暈倒前要扶一下頭 要鋪排一下
暈之前你要扶一扶個頭先 要鋪排㗎嘛
連血漿都有準備
血漿都有準備喎
但你前面表演真的太差了
但你前面啲戲呢確係太屎啦
現在就算加條恐龍 也補救不了
依家就算加條恐龍呢 都救唔番
大家同行交流一下
大家同行交流下姐
不要介意
唔好擺係心度呀
救護車來了 讓開
救護車嚟啦 讓開
讓一下
借借
左胸口第三肋骨輕微骨折 沒有生命危險
左胸口第三肋骨輕微骨折 無生命危險
上擔架床
上擔架
準備 起
小心點
小心啲吓
對不起 阿伯
對唔住啊 阿伯
那個女的是家屬嗎
嗰個女人係家屬啊
她是傻的 別理她
佢係傻㗎 唔駛理佢
救命啊
我的腿
我隻腳啊
停
Cut
你個臨時演員在幹什麼 會不會演戲
你個茄哩啡係度做咩啊 識唔識做戲㗎
受傷一點聲音都沒有 怎能出來混飯吃
受傷一啲聲都無 點出嚟撈啊
是這樣 根據我個人經驗
係咁嘅 根據我個人嘅經驗呢
人在痛苦的時候不一定要大喊大叫的
人係痛苦嘅時候係唔一定要鬼剎咁嘈嘅
你說什麼
你噏乜啊
大叔 你過來一下
阿叔 你過一過嚟吔
麻煩你做個痛苦的反應看看
麻煩你做個痛苦反應睇下
啊
這個是假的
嗱呢啲係假嘅
幫幫忙
幫幫手
這就是真的 沒有聲音吧
呢啲係真㗎啦 無聲㗎
你跟導演說說
你同導演講吓
導演 你覺得呢
導演 你點睇啊
- 我 - 導演
你
滾遠點
死遠啲啦
喂喂喂
需要演死屍的 死人妝兩天不能卸
需要演死屍嘅 死人妝兩日唔落得
- 多少錢 - 誰願意去
- 幾多錢 - 有無人做
兩天四百
兩日四百
加點吧
加啲啦
我來我來
我嚟我嚟
看見臉的嗎
見唔見到樣嘅先
你跟我講條件
你同我講條件啊
看見臉 我不要錢 有飯盒就行
見樣 唔收錢 飯盒就得㗎啦
成交 走
有沒有搞錯
有冇搞錯
神經病
痴線
大家先吃吧 要不涼了
大家食飯先 唔係餸都凍晒啦
你是壽星公 你不吃
你係壽星公 你唔食
誰敢吃啊
邊個夠膽食啊
爸
阿爸
生日快樂
小夢
今天你的妝很特別
今日你嗰裝好特別喎
給你嚇到了
比你嚇親啊
你拍戲好好玩
你拍戲好好玩呀可
我這次演一個死屍
今次呢我演條死屍
有特寫鏡頭的 可以看到演技
有大頭鏡頭 會見到我演技㗎
死屍都能看出演技
死屍都仲睇得到演技
爸
對於一個演員來說 死亡是一種有趣的設定
對於一個演員嚟講 死亡係一種好有趣嘅設定
你想像下
你想像一下
如果你被活生生地砍死了
如果你尷生比人砍死左
那種意境確是
嗰種意境確係
你說什麼
你講咩啊
再說一次
講多次啊
你今天生日不要動氣
你今日生日唔好咁勞氣啦
小夢 不要亂說話 快把妝給卸了
小夢 唔好亂嗡嘢 快啲去落左個妝佢
明天還要繼續拍
聽日仲要繼續拍啊
你真的以為自己是大明星嗎
你真係以為自己係大明星啊
你們是一起長大的吧
你地一齊大㗎係嘛
你看人家B仔
你睇人地B仔呀
已經是大律師了
已經係大律師啦
小小成就何足掛齒
你再看豬豬
你再睇下豬豬啊
多幸福
幾幸福
找到個這麼好的老公
搵到個咁好嘅老公
你再看看你自己
你再睇下你自己
我們希望你當大律師的
我地想你做律師㗎
不是死屍
唔係死屍啊
行行出狀元 律師和死屍都不分貴賤
行行出狀元 律師和死屍都無分貴賤啊
我做臨時演員都是自食其力
我做茄哩啡都係自食其力啊
我也有我的夢想
我都有我嘅夢想㗎
你都三十歲了 做臨時演員都十幾年了
你三十歲啦 茄哩啡做左十幾年嗱
當女主角了嗎
做左女主角未呀
我相信憑我的天賦 加上我的努力
我相信憑我嘅天賦 加上我嘅努力
肯定是最佳女主角
肯定係最佳女主角
對不起 嗆著了
對唔全 濁親
媽 你說對不對
阿媽 你話係咪
你一定可以的
你實得嘅
可以個屁
得個屁
都是你把她寵壞了
一日最衰就係你縱壞佢
不要說我這個爸不給你多一次機會
咪話我做老豆嘅唔比多次機會你
砍死你的這菜刀 給我燒了它
你頭上個把死人刀 同我燒左佢
菜刀能燒的嗎
菜刀燒得著嘅咩
不能燒就砍死你
燒唔著我就砍死你
砍死你
等等
爸 你剛跳起那一下 情緒很飽滿
阿爸 正話你跳起個下 情緒好飽滿啊
你拿著刀再跳一次
你乸起把刀再跳一次
我錄下來
我錄低佢
來 預備跳
嚟 預備 跳
跳吧
跳呀喂
女 你搞什麼
囡 你做乜啊
阿姨 我們先走了
阿姨 我地先走啦
真的不好意思
真係唔好意思啊
滾
扯
我沒生過你
我冇生過你
把你的垃圾都帶走
攞埋你啲垃圾走
爸 這些垃圾是你的
阿爸 呢啲垃圾係你㗎喎
我管它是誰的
我理得你邊個啊
爛泥扶不上牆
爛泥扶唔上牆
不要給我再看見你
你唔好再比我見到你
好了好了 吵夠了 吵夠了嗎
好啦好啦 嘈夠啦 嘈夠未啊
我見你一次打你一次
我見你一鑊打你一鑊
喂
有沒有會做反應的
有冇人識做反應㗎
有
你
做個開心的反應
做個開心反應
傷心反應
好 過來
掂呀 過嚟呀
生氣的反應誰會
嬲嘅反應邊個嚟
我
你
仆街吧
仆街呀你
你來
你嚟
好 非常好
ok 正呀
中絕招的反應誰來
中絕招反應邊個嚟
我
你
請問我具體來說是中了什麼絕招呢
請問我具體嚟講中左咩絕招呢
你問這麼多幹嘛 你可以就做 不可以就滾開
你問咁多嘢做咩呀 你做到就做 做唔到就死開啦
寒冰掌吧
寒冰掌啦
好 寒冰掌
好冷 真的好冷
好冷 好冷啊
你有病就去看病 別在這傳染我
有病去睇醫生啦 唔好係度惹埋我啊
你試試
你試吓
你拉我來這幹什麼 我走了
你帶我嚟呢度做咩嘢呀 我走啦
煲了湯給她喝嘛
煲左湯比佢飲呀嘛
還給她煲湯 這明顯是跟我對著干
仲同佢煲湯 姐係擺明同我作對姐
你就當順道來看一下女兒
你咪當順便嚟睇下個女囉
我見她我就揍她 到時候你別攔著我
我見佢就打鑊佢 到時你唔好攔住我啊
要不連你一塊揍
唔係我連你都打
我都特意避開你 你還送過要來給我罵 你真賤格
我都專登避開你㗎啦 你係都要送埋嚟被我剷嘅 你咁賤格嘅你
要你做個反應要什麼前因後果
叫你做個反應講咩前因後果
我只是想令這角色立體一點
我都係想令個角色立體一啲
立你的命吧 立體
立你條毛咩 立體
都看不見你的臉 你以為你是主演嗎
都見唔到你個死樣 你以為自己係主角啊
跟你說前文後理 你懂嗎
同你講前文後理 你識條鐵咩
懂就不會在這裡做臨時演員
識嘅話就唔駛係度做茄哩啡啦
走 跟我來
走 跟我嚟
好激動
你好
誰呀
邊位呀
好好的說話可以嗎
好好哋講嘢唔得咩
人家演員問你問題 需要發這麼大脾氣嗎
人地演員問你少少問題 需要發咁大脾氣咩
關你屁事
關你鬼事
她對表演這麼認真 你看不見嗎
佢對表演咁認真 你睇唔到咩
誰呀
邊個呀
我說誰你心裡清楚
我講邊個你心照啊
人在做 天在看
小心遭報應
因住比雷劈
神經病 場務
痴線 場務
不好意思
唔好意思啊
你知道我是誰嗎
你知唔知我係邊個呀
不知道
唔知
- 那就好 - 走吧
咁就得嘞 走啦
你好
hi
你剛剛做的那反應很有層次 我覺得很到位
你啱啱做嗰個反應好有層次喎 我覺得好到位
還好吧
算係咁啦
關鍵是想像力 你一定要用心去體會當時的情境
關鍵係想像力 你一定要用心去體會當時嘅情境
太厲害了
真係犀利
我叫李洋
我叫如夢
你也在看這本書
你都睇緊呢本書啊
對啊
係呀
你也喜歡喜劇之王
你都鐘意喜劇之王咩
何止 反轉都會背呀
何止啊 反轉都識背呀
要不要來一段
不如走番轉
現在
依家
不然等什麼
唔係幾時啊
喂
什麼
點呀
走啦
走嗱
是啊
係呀
去哪兒
去邊呀
回家
返屋企
然後呢
上班
返工
不上班行不行
唔返工得唔得呀
不上班你養我
不上班你養我啊
喂
又怎麼了
又點呀
我養你啊
我男朋友來了
我男朋友嚟左啦
錯了 對白不是這樣
錯左 對白唔係咁
不是不是 真是我男朋友來了
唔係呀唔係呀 真係我男朋友嚟呀
走了
走啦
誰啊
邊個嚟㗎
一起工作的
一齊做嘢㗎
真的
真嘅
真的 走吧 再見
係呀 走啦 拜拜
我這條香腸也給你
我呢條腸仔都比埋你呀
一人一半
一人一半啦
我這個月工資有四千 存到我們的結婚基金裡
我呢個月出四千蚊糧 入落我哋個結婚基金啊
你一個月最多賺五千 你給我四千
你一個月最多搵五千 你比四千蚊我
你怎麼生活
你仲點夠洗啊
我有一千就夠了
我有一千蚊名用啦
劇組裡有飯盒 我不用花錢
劇組又有飯盒 我都無錢要洗
我出四千五
我出四千五啦
這五百還給你
呢五百比番你
不是說好了嗎
咪講好左㗎囉
一人一半嗎
一人一半㗎嘛
我以為我愛你夠深
沒想到你愛我一樣深
估唔到你愛我一樣夠深
你真把錢給他呀
你真係比錢佢啊
對啊
係呀
為什麼你不把錢給我
又唔見你比錢我嘅
我又不跟你結婚
我又唔係同你結婚
你跟他還不如跟我
你同佢不如同我好過啦
香皂借我用一下
借舊番皂嚟用呀
你為何一直盯著小米看 你是不是喜歡她
你做咩係咁望住小米呀 你係咪鐘意佢啫
你這樣說我就生氣了
你咁講我就好嬲嘞
看就是喜歡嗎
望就係鐘意咩
看她是否這麼低俗
望佢係睇下佢係咪咁 cheap
她就是這麼低俗
佢真係咁 cheap
你不覺得小米很漂亮嗎
你唔覺得小米好靚女咩
漂亮了不起啊
靚唔係大晒㗎
沒內涵
冇內涵
你知道我為什麼愛你嗎
你知唔知點解我咁愛你呀
為什麼
點解
因為你有品味
當然了
梗係啦
對了
呀係啦
我想帶你去見我爸媽
我想帶你去見我阿爸阿媽
如果他們知道我們在一起 定會很放心
如果佢地知道我哋係埋一齊 真會好放心啫
當然了
當然啦
其實我正在搞一個大項目
其實呢近排我係度搞緊一個大項目
等這事成功之後
等呢件事成功左之後
你爸媽一定會以我為驕傲的
你阿爸阿媽一定會以我為驕傲嘅
你千萬不要告訴別人 我查理
你千祈唔好講比人聽 我查理
就是下一個比爾 . 蓋茨
就係下一個比爾 . 蓋茨
你一來就想當世界第一
你一嚟就想做世界第一
不如先從第二第三開始 會不會踏實些
不如從第二第三開始先啦 會唔會踏實啲呀
我是最踏實的
我係最踏實嘅
比爾 . 蓋茨有幾隻眼睛
比爾 . 蓋茨有幾多隻眼睛
兩隻
我有幾隻眼睛
我有幾多隻眼睛
兩隻
他不比我多 我不比他少
佢無多過我 我無少過佢
對不對 對
係咪先 係呀
他能做到的 我一樣能做到
咁佢可以做到嘅 我一樣可以做到
很有道理
好有道理喎
所以 你要相信自己是最好的
所以 你要相信自己係最好嘅
不是第二第三 你就是第一
唔係第二第三 你就係第一
不要再想著拍什麼網大網劇
唔好再諗住拍咩網大網劇
要拍就拍國際大片
最近真的有一套國際大片 在這裡招中國演員
最近真係有一套國際大片 係呢度搵緊中國演員啊
這就是你的機會了
呢個就係你嘅機會啦
但是那角色是白雪公主
但係個角色係白雪公主喎
你就是白雪公主
你就係白雪公主
我
白雪公主有幾隻眼睛
兩隻
那你有幾隻眼睛
你有幾隻眼睛
兩隻
那為什麼你不能是白雪公主
咁點解你唔可以係白雪公主
告訴我 為什麼
話我知 點解
說啊
講呀嘛
問心吧
問心啦
是不是
係唔係先
有沒有道理
有無道理先
白雪公主
就是你
就係你
喂 你真要去打針啊
喂 你真係諗住去打針呀
因為白雪公主是西方名著
因為白雪公主係西方名著
我想樣子有點外國女子的氣質
所以我想個樣有啲鬼妹嘅氣質
這樣你都想得出來
咁都比你諗到呀
最頂級演員就是這樣
最頂級嘅演員就係咁㗎啦
馬龍 . 白蘭度為了爭取教父裡的角色
馬龍 . 白蘭度為左爭取教父呢嗰角色
花了很多功夫去改變臉型的
仲花左好多功夫去改變個臉型添
整容還不是為了漂亮 講那麼多廢話
整容咪唔係為左靚 仲講咁多廢話
你冤枉我
但是能變漂亮一點當然好
但係變靚啲嘅話 梗係最好啦
我發現了一個變美神器
我發現左一個變靚神器
新氧美容APP
裡面有好多正規機構和個案 做得挺好的
裡面有好多正規機構同個案 做得幾好嘅
我知道一家八十年的老字號
我識得有家八十年嘅老字號喎
在哪
係邊呀
到了
到啦
師傅 我介紹個客人給你
師傅 我介紹個客仔比你
想怎麼做啊
想點整呀
我想做成她這樣
我想整到好似佢咁
要那麼盡嗎
去到咁盡呀
對啊 我是第一次有點緊張
係呀 我第一次㗎咋 有啲緊張
這款我也是第一次 我也緊張
呢款我都係第一次 我都有啲緊張
師傅你是做中國人比較多 對吧
師傅你都係做開中國人多 係咪呀
不怕跟你說
唔怕話你知呀
我做人比較多一點
我做人比較多啲
毛你要做嗎
啲毛你係照整呀
什麼毛
咩毛啊
這全身的毛
咪成身啲毛囉
他們的毛確實比我們濃密
佢哋啲毛確係濃密過我哋嘅
不過一般來說都看不出來
不過一般嚟講都睇唔出㗎
很難看不出來
好難睇唔出㗎喎
你真是很專業 但毛我就不要了
你真係好專業啊 不過毛我就唔駛啦
那太浪費了
咁就嘥晒
這些效果只能維持一兩天
呢啲效果只能夠維持一兩日嘅啫
很簡單 很快就搞定
好簡單 好快趣搞掂㗎啦
師傅 我想把鼻子做得翹翹的
師傅 個鼻我想整到竅竅哋喎
你再翹就變成鴛鴦火鍋了
再竅就打邊爐鴛鴦鍋㗎啦
鴛鴦鍋
打邊爐
隨便吧 你喜歡就好
是但啦 你鐘意就得啦
師傅
你總是看那猩猩是什麼原理
你係咁望住隻猩猩係咩原理呀
我不看那猩猩怎麼整
我唔望住猩猩點整呀
為什麼呢
有啲咁嘅事
你要整成猩猩這樣嘛
你要整隻猩猩咁樣呀嘛
我不是要整這個
我唔係整呢個
是這個啊
係呢個呀
你不早說
你唔早啲講
我要照鏡子
我照照鏡先
你別照了 會把你嚇死的
你唔好照啦 咪一陣嚇死你啊
我幫你搞定 包在我身上
我幫你搞掂 包係我身上
躺下吧
訓低呀
好的 搞定了
好嘢 搞掂晒
整得怎麼樣 看看
整成點呀 睇下
可以嗎
得唔得呀
好美啊
好靚呀
真的嗎
係咪架
美到不得了
靚到鬼火咁啊
現在真不得了
嗱 而家真係好嘢啦
下一個
那邊等
過去等
幹什麼
做咩呀
我來試鏡
試什麼
試咩呀
白雪公主
為什麼
點解呀
因為我來試鏡白雪公主
因為我係嚟試白雪公主
你再說一次
你再講多次
為什麼說那麼多次
點解要講咁多次
我怕我聽錯
我驚我聽錯
我來試鏡白雪公主
我嚟試白雪公主
你再說一遍
你再講多次
算了 打擾了
咁由佢啦 打搞晒
站住 還走
企係度 仲走
給我攔住前面那東西
幫我截住前面隻嘢呀
手足快來幫忙 別讓她跑了
手足快啲過嚟幫忙 唔好比佢跑走
攔住她
攔住佢
抓住她
捉住佢
別走
唔好走呀
攔住她
攔住佢
跟我來
跟我嚟
還想跑
仲想走
看你走去哪裡
睇你走得去邊
還走
走啊嗱
對不起 我一時貪心才來試鏡的
對唔住 我一時貪心先嚟試鏡嘅
給我個機會
比次機會我呀
老闆你看
老闆你睇
怎處理
點處理
幹活
做嘢
不要啊
唔好呀
我以後都不敢了
我以後都唔敢㗎啦
頸圍三十三
開工 開工
袖長六十
為什麼呢
點解嘅
不要動
唔好郁
請問發生什麼事
請問發生咩事呢
我們選了你
我哋揀左你啦
導演 我這邊差不多準備好了
導演 我呢邊差唔多得啦
選了我
揀左我
我們隨時可以出發
我哋隨時行得喇
演員好了就過來
演員得就埋位啦
來了 演員出發
嚟緊 演員嚟緊
請問 現在拍的這場戲是描述什麼的
請問聲 而家呢場戲係描述啲咩㗎
可以的 拍完馬上告訴你
得㗎啦 拍完之後話你知呀
那你想我用什麼手法去演繹這個角色呢
咁你想我用咩手法去演繹呢個角色呢
好極了
無問題啦
就這麼說定了 演員到現場
一於係係咁話啦 演員到現場
就位
埋位
好 站著別動
好 企係度咪郁
你好
Hi
開機
開始
Action
停
Cut
好了 拍演員
Ok 拍演員
替身走開 演員就位
替身走開 演員埋位
替身走開 拉她出去
替身走 拖出去啦
快點
快啲啦
走開走開
行開行開
開始
Action
我不怕 你們就打死我吧
我唔驚 你地就打死我啦
停
Cut
好了
Ok
繼續打
演員休息 替身就位
演員休息 替身埋位
辛苦了 辛苦了
辛苦哂 辛苦哂
- 來了 - 抬起頭來
嚟啦 齕起個頭啦
抬起頭來
齕起個頭
- 醒醒啊 - 手舉起來
喂 舉起手
手指舉起來 幹活了
喂 舉起個手指呀 搵食呀
撐好 不要縮
頂住呀 唔好縮呀
開始
Action
停
Cut
換演員
開始
Action
想不到你們真的打死我
估唔到你哋真係打死我
- 停 - 停
- Cut - Cut
非常好
七個小矮人終於為白雪公主報了仇
七個小矮人終於為白雪公主報左仇
真的很感動
真係好感動
導演
我不是演白雪公主的嗎
我唔係演白雪公主㗎咩
你幹什麼
你搞咩
走走走
- 對不起 導演 - 快點拖她出去
- 對唔住 導演 - 快啲拖佢出去
導演
不好意思導演
唔好意思導演
準備拍白雪公主
收到
馬老師
叫那個過氣明星快點 全村人在等他
叫嗰個過氣明星快啲呀 全村都等緊佢呀
說誰過氣
邊個過氣呀
我
說話小心點
講嘢小心啲呀
是
係
閃開閃開 馬老師來了
閃開閃開 馬老師嚟啦
拍完這場就轉場
拍埋呢場就轉場
導演 女版白雪公主你選哪個
導演 女版白雪公主你揀邊個
漂亮點就好 只有一個鏡頭
揀個靚啲得㗎啦 得一個鏡頭啫
馬老師來了 大家冷靜點
馬老師嚟啦 大家冷靜啲
注意了 大家閃開 彈開
注意喇 大家閃開 閃開
大家借開 借開
大家借歪 借歪
不要湧過來 你還湧過來
唔好湧埋嚟 你仲湧埋嚟
大家冷靜點 不要亂來
大家冷靜啲 唔好亂嚟
不要摸 不要拍照
唔好摸 唔準影相
馬老師
我們今天這場戲是你演的白雪公主
我哋今日呢場戲係你演嘅白雪公主
被巫婆陷害
比巫婆陷害
你吃了毒香蕉之後變成了男人
你食左毒香蕉之後變左男人
王子喝多了 一時不為意
王子飲大左 一時唔為意
跟你睡了
同你上左床
是我睡他 還是他睡我
咁係我砌佢定佢砌我
都有
王子醒了後 發現你是男的
王子醒番之後 發現你係男人
沒有辦法接受 所以要把你殺掉
無辦法接受 所以要隊冧你
但是卻被你反殺
但係點知反比你隊冧
王子的所有手下到處追殺你
王子嘅所有手下四圍追殺你
你逃到了唐人街被砍了
你走到去唐人街被人砍
你身受重傷 連腸子都流出來了
你身受重傷連條腸都流埋出嚟
會不會太殘忍
會唔會殘忍左啲呢
其實我是想向張徹導演的暴力美學致敬
其實我係想向張徹導演嘅暴力美學致敬
張徹的暴力美學
張徹嘅暴力美學
您懂不懂
你曉唔曉
好啊
不是好 是懂不懂
唔係好 係曉唔曉
你覺得呢
你話呢
我不方便說
我唔係好方便講
我當然懂 腸都爆出來嘛
我曉梗係曉啦 腸都爆出來呀嘛
這個好 這個好
呢個好 呢個好
我們先拍你的腸爆出來 所以很生氣的反應 好嗎
我地先拍你啲腸爆出來 所以好嬲嘅反應 ok
好 準備
馬老師 我給你掛好這腸子
馬老師 我幫你掛埋條腸先
開機
第一次
Take One
開始
Action
我
我很生氣
我好嬲呀
停
Cut
馬老師可不可以真的生氣
馬老師可唔可以真係嬲
我都已經說我很生氣
我咪講左我好嬲囉
你們聽到嗎
你地聽唔聽到呀
只有你聽不到 我說出來了
係得你聽唔到咋喎 我都講到出口啦
難道是假的嗎
仲有假㗎咩
我不方便說
我唔方便講
不方便就不要說 誰逼你說
唔方便講唔好講 邊個逼你講啫
那能不能加點女人味
咁可唔可以加番啲女人味呢
我早就說了要加點女人味
我早就話要加啲女人味㗎啦
畢竟我是個公主
話晒我都係個公主嚟㗎嘛
等你說就死人了
等你就死得啦
來來來
come on come on
再來一次
one more time
開始
Action
我很生氣
我嬲到呢
我真的很生氣
我真係嬲到呢
搞什麼
哇搞咩呀
這什麼意思啊
咁咩意思啊
停 對白錯了
Cut 對白錯左
我去你的 你覺得我是在說對白嗎
我頂你個肺啊 你覺得我似係講緊對白咩
我的腸為什麼是火腿腸
我條腸點解係火腿腸嚟㗎
馬老師你聽我說 我們春節檔不能太殘忍
馬老師你聽我講 我地春節檔唔可以太殘忍
你剛剛不是都說爆腸定律嗎
你頭先唔係話爆腸定律㗎咩
是暴力美學 大件事了
係暴力美學 大件事啦
馬老師生氣了 大家要留意了
馬老師扯火啦 大家要留意啦
我剛才的演技都爆出來了
我頭先啲演技爆緊出嚟啦
你們為什麼不配合我呢
你地做咩唔配合我呢
因為我們的對象是家庭觀眾 有很多小朋友的
因為我哋嘅對象係家庭觀眾 有好多小朋友嘅
所以暴力美學中也要有天真可愛的感覺
所以暴力美學入面都要有天真可愛嘅感覺
我看到我自己的腸是一條火腿腸
咁我見到自己條腸係一條火腿腸
我會笑出來的
我會笑㗎嘛
怎麼投入呢
我點投入到呢
這些商業考慮真的很難給你解釋
呢啲商業考量真係好難解釋你聽嘅
你這麼偉大的演員
你咁偉大嘅演員
一條火腿腸難不倒你的
一條火腿腸難唔倒你嘅
當然難不倒我
咁梗係難我唔到啦
但你們真的太不尊重觀眾了吧
但係你地真係太唔尊重觀眾啊嘛
春節檔
要不要再加一個天真可愛的腎
咁駛唔駛呀 加多個天真可愛嘅腎添啊
道具 趕快多加一個腎 在
道具 嗱嗱聲加多個腎 係
收到 馬上做
收到 即做
導演 你覺得這個行不行
導演 呢個得唔得呀
加番茄醬看看
蘸啲茄汁睇下
好
嘩 又暴力又天真呀
是這意思
係咁嘅意思啊
大家準備 演員站好
大家準備 演員企好
去你的 還不叫停
頂你呀 仲唔 cut
累得要死
攰到仆街
大家注意了 注意了
大家注意啦 注意啦
馬老師來了 閃開 閃開
馬老師嚟啦 閃開 閃開
大家注意了 馬老師來了
大家注意啦 馬老師嚟啦
垃圾導演拍垃圾電影
垃圾導演拍埋啲垃圾戲
若是以前我早打他一巴掌了
比住我係以前大巴星佢啦
現在為什麼不打
咁你而家唔星佢
我現在有修養呀
咁我而家係有修養呀嘛
你笑什麼
你笑咩
你這傻瓜
你個蛤𧊅
你在笑我嗎
你笑緊我啊
我都沒笑你 你還笑我
我都未笑你 你走嚟笑我
我很好笑嗎
我好好笑咩
大家注意了 馬老師踢腳了
大家注意啦 馬老師起腳啦
沒開玩笑 馬老師踢腳了
唔講得笑呀 馬老師起腳啦
不要摸 不要拍照
唔好摸 唔好影相啊
控制一下自己
控制下自己
夢姐
真的是你
真係你呀
李洋
對啊
係呀
你這特效化妝
你嘅特技妝
是啊
係呀
剛剛怎麼回事
頭先咩事呀
沒事
無嘢啊
你吃我的吧
你食我呢盒啊
不用了
唔駛啦
對不起 帥哥
唔好意思啊 靚仔
我想再拿一個飯盒
我要多個飯盒得唔得啊
一人一盒
做臨時演員 還想著佔便宜
做個茄哩啡 都係度呃飯食
走
你下次再敢來 報警抓你
你下次再敢嚟呀嗱 我報警拉你啊
我上次就跟你們說過了
我上次都同你地講過㗎啦
人在做 天在看
你們為什麼要這樣
點解你地係都要咁嘅呢吓
什麼事
咩呀
飯盒做出來是不是讓人吃的
飯盒做出嚟係咪比人食嘅
說什麼
你嗡咩呀
你說
你講
答我
什麼答你什麼
咩呀答你咩啫
飯盒做出來是不是讓人吃的
飯盒整出嚟係咪比人食嘅
是啊 怎麼了
係呀 做咩啫
那為什麼她沒有
咁點解佢冇
誰是她
邊個佢呀
就是化了特效妝的女子
就係化特效妝嗰個女仔
答我
你說啊
你講啊
你冷靜點
你冷靜啲先
為什麼她沒飯盒 你鎮定點
點解佢冇飯盒 你定啲嚟呀喂
為什麼她沒有飯盒
點解佢冇飯盒
喂喂喂
你剛才為什麼拿個瓶子打自己
頭先你做咩用個樽鏗自己呀
難道我打他嗎
唔通我鏗佢呀
沒看到他多高大
你睇唔到佢幾大隻
有沒有見到女兒
有無見到個女呀
沒有
冇
這麼就走
就咁就走嗱
走
你知不知我 前幾天在劇組碰見馬可
你知唔知呀 前幾日我係劇組見到馬可
- 誰是馬可 - 馬可啊
- 邊個馬可 - 馬可啊
- 誰啊 - 算了
- 姐係邊個 - 唉是但啦
他那天不知是否心情不好 一腳把我飯盒打翻了
佢個日唔知係咪心情唔好呢 一腳踢左我盒飯落地呀
我去再要一盒 那帥哥死活不給
咁我咪想去攞過盒囉 阿靚仔又死都唔肯比喎
那我要走時 他突然又給我一盒飯
咁我走啦 咁點知佢又無厘頭比番盒飯我喎
你說我是不是開始走運呢
咁你話我係咪開始行運呢
你這個臨時演員會不會想太多了
你呢個茄喱啡會唔會諗太多呀
又不要看不起臨時演員
又唔好睇唔起茄喱啡
很多大明星都是由臨時演員做起的
好多大明星都係由茄喱啡做起嘅
孫儷 劉嘉玲 趙麗穎
你條件有她們好嗎
你條件有佢地咁好咩
我比她們還要好
我好過佢哋添啦
因為我比她們還要努力
因為我勤力過佢哋
你都神經病的
你都痴孖根㗎
總之 機會就是留給努力的人
總之呢 機會係留比努力嘅人嘅
不可能你站在大街上 就有人拉你當明星
唔通呀 你就咁企係條街度 就會有人埋嚟搵你做明星咩
小姐
有沒興趣拍戲
有無興趣拍戲呀
你是誰
你邊個嚟㗎
她是監製
佢係監製嚟㗎
你好 我是演員小夢
你好 我係演員小夢
你好 我們有一部戲正在找人
你好 我哋有一套戲而家搵緊人
有沒有興趣試一試
有無興趣試下
有 我很有興趣
有呀 我好有興趣呀
不好意思
唔好意思
不是你
唔係你
是你
係你
我
對 一直都是在問你
係呀 一路都係問緊你咋嘛
去試試吧 我們公司就在上面
去試下啦 我地公司就係上面之嘛
不要這樣
唔好咁啦
當作是玩就好
當係玩下咋嘛
不要哭
喊咩啫
他們選了我當女主角
佢地揀左我做女主角呀
真的
真㗎
我什麼都不會 選我幹什麼
我乜都唔識 揀我做咩喎
我進去他們要我把妝卸了 然後說了兩句對白
我入到去 佢地要我落左個妝 然後講兩句對白
那人就說是我了 我現在該怎麼辦啊
嗰個人就話係我啦 我而家點算好啊
什麼怎麼辦啊 多好的機會
咁點算好啫 咁好嘅機會
換作是我短五十年命 我都願意
如果比著係我短五十年命 我都制呀
但是我不想呀
我現在很害怕 我不想當演員
別這樣 不要哭
我這麼純情 不可以被娛樂圈污染我的
我不介意被人污染
不如你跟他們說 讓我替你
我跟他們說了 求了他們很久
要他們找你 他們死都不要
死都不要
對 死都不要
- 死都不要 - 怎麼辦呀
車在那邊
好的 事情都辦好了啊
- 放心吧 都辦好了 - 嗨
你怎麼還在
對 真的很多謝你給我機會
- 好好把握 - 嗯
要不要送你
好呀 我家很近的
謝謝
坐後面吧
小米這麼快就搬走了
全都搬走了
我的香皂和衛生巾都拿走了
我早說過她
俗
為什麼我要和小米一起吃飯
如果小米不在的話 他們一定會選我的
就算小米不在 他們也不一定會選你
機會不是留給努力的人嗎
就是說這不是你的機會
這是小米的機會
但是她不努力 機會就成了誤會
繼續堅持 你的機會一定會出現的
對 我以後一定要更加努力
把我的履歷發遍全中國
我要讓世人知道
什麼才是演技
說得好
千萬不要有負面情緒
就像我的計劃還欠點資金 也沒影響我
還差多少
兩萬
不如先拿結婚基金的錢
不可以 不然我們就永遠結不了婚了
不如我加班或找份兼職
不要擔心 你先做好你自己
不然我會心痛
大哥
不好意思
我最近缺錢 有沒有價高一點的角色
你睡醒了嗎 你憑什麼
憑我什麼都可以做 不揀擇
來吧幫幫忙 好不好
停
有沒有搞錯
她很完美
走開 都不知道你說什麼
誰找來的替身
我求求你 大嬸 快穿上衣服
- 快走 - 大白天跑出來嚇人
對不起 導演
我不知道她脫了衣服這麼糟糕
你在耍我嗎 找這種貨色回來
又沒身材 皮膚又皺
屁股還有漬
不好意思 導演
如果這都可以的話 不如我來吧
- 快點給我換人 - 夢姐
你沒事吧
沒事
導演嫌我身材差 皮膚皺 又有漬
求我快點把衣服穿上
我挺開心的
問野風 踏遍幾多長路
方可見到理想都
踏破多少波浪和荒土
至能含笑地停步
風卻沒理由起始與終
它只知發力去沖
從未多過問亦從沒關心
路長和浪濤洶涌
風呀 讓我一起去沖
不分春秋與夏冬
無論多遠近 願懷著天真
不須計那天才可終
如內心有夢 便全力追蹤
好比天空疾勁野風
導演導演
等一下我演的雕像是動還是不動
媽的 你見過會動的雕像嗎
沒有 那為什麼不用真的雕像
真的很貴的 信不信我打你
夢姐 演雕像有沒有什麼秘訣
透過想像力進入無生命體狀態
我試試
現在拍第四場
王子起床發現白雪公主原來是男人
各部門準備 開機
第四場鏡號一 一次
開始
你是誰
白雪公主
我睡了你
停
你會不會演戲
你的角色是騙色的
這麼傷心幹嗎
什麼
你的角色是騙色的
你不用傷心 明白嗎
什麼但是
導演 找人教他英文
來 拍我反殺他的特寫
所有人我沒時間 快點
馬老師對白記住了
化了灰都記得了 快點
好準備
開始
什麼對白
停
千錯萬錯都是我肉體的錯
你這個負心人
好 再來
開始
千錯萬錯
誰的錯
停
千錯萬錯都是我肉體的錯
你這個負心人
好了 知道你厲害 拍啊
千錯萬錯
都是我肉條的錯
停
對不起馬老師 是肉體
怎麼了
都一樣 只是發音差一點
因為我們春節檔很多小朋友
發音準確點比較好
小朋友還管你發什麼音
要不你說1 2345 我們後期配音
數1 23
你侮辱我嗎
不是 這樣方便一點
方便你不早說 我辛苦地演了大半天
你現在才說 你這該死的人
來 拍 拍
來準備
開始
123...
停
你們不要騷擾我 靜點 拍啊
123456...
...8
停
還要數123 這麼刁鑽
試問世上有誰能數得到
我中文不好說英語對白 算了
好 準備
開始
千錯萬錯
都是我肉體的錯
你這個
負心人
他在幹什麼
停
馬老師 你怎麼了
這麼簡單的英語你都不懂嗎
我真的不懂 剛才發生什麼事
你當然不懂 是你迫我的
我來了
大家注意了
馬老師講戲了 大家站穩了
不拍照 不要摸
我親手一刀殺死了我的愛人
那些情感複雜到極點
傷心 恐懼 自私 虛榮
驕傲 興奮 害羞等等
那些情感
總是這樣
然後又不停那樣
你懂什麼 你還喊停
對不起 我剛剛以為你撞鬼
撞鬼
我的演技在大爆發 你說我撞鬼
你們看到了的 大家親眼看到我爆的
你在做什麼
我馬可在這講戲你居然睡覺
對不起 馬老師
又是你
來 你過來
雕塑這麼乾淨一點質感都沒有
怎麼拍電影
我昨晚睡得不好 不是故意的
來 躺下
快點 快點
對了
不要動 又沒有質感
又這麼乾淨 怎麼拍電影
會好看嗎
不髒能有質感嗎
弄來弄去還是不髒
算了算了 這個雕塑不用了
所有人 來吧
快點 快點
看什麼 快點
喂
最近好嗎 還順利嗎
挺好的 媽 很順利
順利就好
一定要記著
在外要虛心的向其他人學習
你說過好多遍了 我都記著了
我和你爸呀
就是擔心你在外面給人欺負
不會的
這裡每個人都很喜歡我的 真的
那就好
對了 媽
爸還生我氣嗎
沒有了
你爸他頭痛 在休息
你替我跟爸說
我很愛你們
你說什麼
再說一遍 大聲點
去你的 走開啦
臨時演員卸妝在外面
感動嗎
去你的
怎麼了
感動嗎
夢姐
夢姐 你沒事吧
李洋
我求你別再問我有沒有事了 好不好
你的臉 太過分
你幹什麼 別給我找事了
我缺錢 還得找工作
你不早說 我什麼都缺就是不缺錢
你要多少 我給你
你別再玩我了
連你都是這樣
你還嫌我不夠慘嗎
我都是想幫忙
如果你真的想幫我的話 就給我死遠點
對不起
願我會楂火箭 帶你到天空去
在太空中兩人住
活到一千歲 都一般心醉
有你在身邊多樂趣
共你雙雙對 好得戚好得意
地林天崩當閒事
就算翻風雨 只需睇到你
似見陽光千萬里
有了你開心啲 乜都稱心滿意
咸魚白菜也好好味
我與你永共敘 分分鐘需要你
你似是陽光空氣
扮靚啲皆因你 癲癲地皆因你
為你甘心作傻事
扮嚇猩猩叫 睇到乜都笑
有你在身邊多樂趣
若有朝失咗你 花開都不美
願到荒島去長住
做個假的你 天天都相對
對木頭公仔做戲
有了你開心啲 乜都稱心滿意
咸魚白菜也好好味
我與你永共敘 分分鐘需要你
你似是陽光空氣
停
馬老師 這是整部戲的第一個鏡頭
你吃了毒香蕉發現自己變成了男人
我想要一種發自內心的恐懼
不然整部戲就不能成立了
不是那種
是真的害怕那種
好 你演一個我看看
可以通過眼神去表達
停
不知你做什麼
再來
是那感覺真的在裡面
停
你這樣的演 整個戲就不能成立的
再來一次
譬如你可以
停停停
別演了 回家休息吧
其實
停
滾開
你覺得怎麼樣
是不是很難受
不方便說
出來工作 你給我面子
我給你面子 就可以了
你有這麼必要較真嗎
場務
帶他去洗手間 洗個頭
很髒
蘇導演
馬老師
你有看新聞嗎
沒看 什麼事 快說
前幾天被你羞辱的臨時演員 記得嗎
怎麼了
她死了
怎麼死的
上吊自殺
還穿了件紅色衣服 怨氣太重了
那個人在那裡幹什麼
什麼人
穿紅色衣服 對著牆的那個
看不見嗎
馬老師 別玩了
要拍他很驚恐的特寫
好的
導演 我對牆幹什麼
前面不是牆 是海
你在溜冰場看海
你發現了心上人馬老師
不敢直視很害羞的四十五度角
回頭望他
然後滑到牆後再望他 明白嗎
明白
開始
現在你鼓起勇氣
很興奮地把項鏈送給他作為定情信物
開始
送給你
這個好停
就是這個 完美
導演 他
他尿褲子了 為什麼
沒事 你等一下
對不起 馬老師 你別生氣
我要的就是這種感覺
你做得到的 我們準備拍攝
我不拍了
我現在要去醫院
你們死定了
等收律師信吧
你不要怪我們
我們只是想效果好一點
你想要什麼效果可以跟我說
我這國際級的演員 你說得出 我做得到
我一直都有跟你說你一直做不到
那你們就用這喪盡天良的方法
來對付我了嗎
大家注意了 注意了 馬老師尿褲子
你說什麼
大家注意了 馬老師不是尿褲子
只是褲子有尿漬
我忍你這四眼龜很久了
我馬可從影幾十年
從來沒有受過今天這麼大的侮辱
一個臨時演員
竟可欺負一個國際巨星
發生什麼事
還有王法嗎
你還敢站在這
對不起 對不起
你別走
你走
對 你都走
是你 馬可 你走
其實你們年輕人
因為經驗不足 用這種方式
我完全是
可以理解的
你知否我為何要用這種方式
因為你的演技太爛了
我演技爛 那為什麼你還要請我呢
因為你便宜 只有你有時間
你過氣那麼多年了
我以為你有這個機會會好好珍惜
但是不是
你失敗是有原因的
你根本就不配做演員
沒時間了 天都快亮了
大家同心地拍好戲
做到最好 來吧 來吧 快點
不用了 我們換人
你不要欺人太甚 我已經讓步了
欺人太甚不是你嗎
我們聊聊
做事吧 開工了 不要看
導演
其實你能給我這個角色 真的很感激你
我做夢都想著怎樣報答你
麻煩你馬上把劇本還給我
別這樣 我已經七八年沒有工作了
這個機會對我很重要 給我個面子
我分你一半片酬
好嗎
幫幫忙
幫不了你
把劇本拿回來
不好意思
別這樣
放手
- 給馬老師一個面子 幫幫忙 - 放手
真的對不起
我不是故意嚇你的
不用說了
我不知道情節是這樣的
我不需要你可憐我
一來到這裡 我就想打人
你這樣是打人嗎 你是打自己
馬可
好久不見你 原來你還有拍戲
你沒我長得高 你的皮膚開始鬆了
爸 媽
這是我女兒
- 來 - 幹什麼
我們來張自拍照片
拍什麼 別拍了
走開吧
比個心 老公
- 比什麼心 - 比個心
乖 阿姨疼你
笑一個 123
夠了 真不好意思 打擾你
馬可
我女兒小的時候
就是看了你的 《孤兒尋親記》
才喜歡演戲
你可以說是她的啟蒙老師
媽別說了
馬老師 不好意思
我們全家都是你的影迷
馬先生
我女兒就是不聽我的
她不是幹這行的材料
你可否幫我勸勸她
她很努力
她會成功的
多謝你 馬老師
李洋
你今天的戲服很漂亮
還行吧
這是哪個大明星的車
夢姐 這裡二十萬夠不夠
不夠我再叫人去取
你別胡鬧 拿劇組道具鈔要坐牢的
老闆
時間差不多了 該走了
等一下 給我點時間 很快就好
夢姐 你拿去吧
不用了
我找了份兼職 自己能搞定
那好吧
原來你真的這麼有錢
家裡做生意 有一點錢
那還出來當臨時演員
興趣
但很快要去國外接管生意
不能再來玩了
你好厲害
哪裡 那我走了
還有
其實我很喜歡你
我也喜歡你
不是 不是這種 是男女的那種
我當你是朋友 你居然想睡我
對啊
你喜歡我什麼
你心地善良
又是這種話 意思就是我醜
不是 你長得也很美
太假了 想像力
來個真一點的
你真的很美
你也太假了吧
也不能怪你 我確實是醜
對
你很壞 真的
我有男朋友了
我知道
還是要謝謝你
那我走了
記得回來看我
去美國 一時間回不來
大老闆 很羨慕你
是我羨慕你
可以做自己喜歡做的事
加油啊
你好
外賣到了
麻煩給個五星好評 謝謝
小米
試一下
好久不見了 你還好嗎
你認識她
嗯
陳導演
真的是你 太感動了
導演我是你的粉絲
我很喜歡看你的電影
謝謝
試試這件
我也是個演員 我叫如夢
如果可以的話 可否給我一個機會
什麼角色都可以
好
真的
太好了
我一直在等這個機會
很感激你 我一定不會讓你失望的
非常好
謝謝
我不打擾你們
不好意思
導演 你看看這場戲
導演 請問你打算什麼時候開拍
我預留時間給你
你們很熟嗎
不熟
我們再通知你
你先出去吧 謝謝
打擾你一下
導演我能加你的微信嗎
我可以隨時來試鏡
沒有微信 你怎麼還不出去
不要緊
借筆一用 我給導演留個電話
- 你可以隨時通知我 很快 - 走了
好
謝謝你
我不會通知你
走了
導演不是說會通知我嗎
等等
我剛才是客氣不想傷害你
你從來不照鏡子嗎
每天都照
你覺得你有機會嗎
我有
你沒有
我明白 機會是很難得
我可以等
你不用等
永遠都沒有
永遠是多遠
永遠就是從現在直到宇宙滅亡
明白嗎
那宇宙滅亡之後呢
有你的 人類最大的災難就是你這種人
又不行 又沒有自知之明
還不死心 整天出來搞事情
我們要吃飯你不是送飯的嗎
對不起導演 打擾了你
我帶她出去
走啦
你搞什麼 丟不丟人
我只是想爭取一下
算了吧 這是命
知道什麼是命嗎
什麼是命
我不想當明星 卻當了
你這麼想當明星 但你就是個臨時演員
這就是命
不要與命運作對了 好嗎
查理 你在哪
我在陪客戶
我想見你
我一會兒還要開會 忙得快瘋掉了
我再打給你
等一下 你別掛
什麼事
你今天穿什麼衣服
我每天都穿同一套衣服
白襯衣黑西褲
問這個幹什麼
沒事 我隨便問一下
再說吧 拜拜
我們找個地方坐的士吧
好
在哪裡坐
就前面
好大的雨
這麼巧 表姐
親愛的 我看到我表姐 你等我一下
她是誰
客戶
為什麼我是表姐
隨便吧 怎麼說都是一句
我去問問她
她確實是我客戶 你也是我客戶
我是提供服務的 好了吧
什麼服務
就是那種
合約男友
你出來賣
隨便吧 怎麼說都是一句
為什麼又是我
是我命不好嗎
還是因為我蠢
不要說出來
蠢人好 蠢人多快樂
好
把結婚基金的錢還給我
這些錢
我會一直替你保管的 你別擔心
你要的錢
我幫你籌夠了
你要騙就騙吧
我不是騙
我是收費的
不是總是想吃霸王餐 好不好
其實你從來不覺得
我做演員會成功的 對吧
你會成功的
你是最棒的
你再給我錢 我再繼續說
說多少次都可以
你別哭 她會懷疑我的
你還哭
別搞我了
為什麼你
你別打爛我飯碗
表姐都叫你不要吸毒
會害死你的
不要再找我借錢
回頭是岸吧 表姐
做得好 親愛的
不應借錢給她
借錢給她是害她
沒事嗎
你睡著了 還是喝醉了
你不是自殺吧
當然不是
難道你是在拍戲 你是演員嗎
不是
我不是演員
我醒了
都說你睡著了 很危險的
不要再這樣
副導你好
馬老師 好久不見
演什麼
一個英勇陣亡的軍人
非常好 躺在那邊
快
服裝化妝 準備好了嗎
是躺在這裡嗎
就這樣躺在一起 你們的頭靠近點
沒光了 快點啦
我是睜開眼死 還是閉著眼死
隨便啦 誰看得見啊
那我就睜開眼死吧
因為在這戰亂當中來說 國仇家恨
應該是死不瞑目
別動
準備
開始
保護長官
衝啊
快走
我掩護你
衝啊
你看怎麼回事
在哪裡看的
騰訊微視
你看
嚇到尿褲子
你看馬可這傻瓜
你知道馬可嗎
不知道
不是
他真尿出來
我看了很多次
我每次看都笑死我
以前不覺得他拍喜劇
這條視頻真的很爆
馬可
- 你是馬可嗎 - 真是馬可嗎
挺像的
真的嗎
- 是馬可 - 哇 真的是馬可
馬可真人比上鏡漂亮
能和我照張相嗎
- 我就喜歡你的 - 我們自拍
看鏡頭
不會吧 真的嗎
慢慢來 慢慢來
一起拍照 守秩序 不要爭
你那個視頻超級搞笑 我好喜歡看
馬老師你好 今天很高興能邀請到你
你最近可以說是咸魚翻生 有什麼感覺
什麼咸魚翻生
就是說你最近很紅
為什麼我是咸魚呢
我
意思是我死了嗎
對不起 我絕對不是這個意思
那為什麼說我是咸魚呢
我很咸嗎
演得好
這是基本
馬老師的演技真厲害 隨時都可爆出來
對 因為你要爆的時候真的控制不了
你能否給我們示範一下
你那個嚇尿的經典表情
等等 應該會有很多小朋友在看
我們都是不要做這動作
對啊 那你接下來有什麼計劃呢
又是那些國際大片 還有什麼
我見過馬可 那視頻就是我嚇他的
你是拍戲的嗎
對 我以前是演員
你有沒見過李小龍
我什麼龍都見
喂
去收拾餐桌 還在聊天
你的人生絕對是大起大落
你有什麼想說
其實我覺得自己很幸運
這些經歷不是人人都可以有
我真的很想感謝在視頻中嚇我的那個人
正所謂沒有她就沒有我今天
她是誰
我不知道她的名字 但是
她是個演員
小夢
你看誰來了
你今天真的很帥 很整齊
馬老師
馬可哥
如夢 我終於找到你
我專門來感謝你的
她其實沒做什麼
只是嚇得你尿褲子而已
我每天都給她嚇得尿褲子
我不會多謝她的
來來來 坐坐坐
來來來
好香
你最近很紅啊
多得你長得這麼恐怖
你們怎麼生她的
你真壞
像她爸
像她媽
都像
恭喜你
入圍了星爺新電影的選角
什麼
你不知道嗎
這次說了要選一些實力派的新面孔
我看到你的名字
在哪裡
在網上
明天在北京面試 你看
- 收不到 - 不好意思
沒關係 我不去了
為什麼
我現在有新工作
不做演員了
是嗎
我現在在一家餐廳做侍應生
還開了一間網店 收入還不錯
爸媽都很開心
小夢現在很踏實的 是好事
現在很好
盛碗湯給馬可哥
挺好的
怎麼了
有點不舒服
你更年期嗎
胡說 人家那麼年輕
是心臟病嗎
- 趕快找醫生 - 不用了 沒事
- 家人知道嗎 - 沒事 不用擔心
我只是見小夢現在過得這麼好
心裡有點不舒服
你們不要誤會
我只是覺得
好像一個打不死的拳王
突然還沒打 你就投降了
我不是投降只不過是有自知之明
不再做明星夢了
這就是投降
馬老師
十幾年來
我每天都被嘲笑被拒絕
根本沒人想看我演戲
也沒人尊重過我一秒鐘
我受夠了
為什麼呢
什麼為什麼
為什麼要投降
這不是投降
是
我自己根本就不行
這個世界不是你努力就能成功的
我早就跟你說了 你就是不聽
隨她吧 她總是被人欺負
我知道 完全明白
我也感同身受
其實 我這次來是專門說聲謝謝的
我還有事 先走了
真的這麼快走
馬可 吃了飯再走
對呀 馬老師
我覺得
只要不投降 就是成功
還是你教的我
不如我去試試
我早就知道你會這樣
你說你有什麼用
走吧 走
幫她訂票
火車還是飛機
- 飛機 - 哦 飛機
訂頭等艙
滾
不用這麼多 爸
拿去
你就是個爛泥扶不上牆 你
訂好票了 趕快走吧
是頭等艙嗎
當然
多謝你 媽
爸 親一下
臭丫頭 你以後不要再回來
好呀
家裡鑰匙拿了嗎
拿了
我是機械人
好 下一個
早晨
我是一隻正在發育的冬菇
下一個
快點
媽媽
爺爺 奶奶
舅父 表哥
姐夫
姨媽
好慘啊
我全家都被鏟泥車撞死了
太好了 下一個
你好
可以了 下一個
不好意思 我醞釀一下 五分鐘就好
一百多人在等 五分鐘
謝謝
做得好 下一個
你好
我可以用手發聲
下一個
對不起
現在是才藝表演
白癡
你好
我演一位英雄
好 開始
我陳真今天一定要報仇
是誰害死我師父
評審老師 你好
我演一個間諜
開始
老闆 不要啊
打牌就打牌
你做什麼 你弄痛我
不要這樣
不要用皮帶
你好
快點
我演一個騙子
開始
快點 一百多人在等
表姐
親愛的 我看見表姐 你等我一下
她是誰
客戶
為什麼我是表姐
隨便 怎麼說都是一句
我去問問她
她的確是我客戶 你都是我客戶
我是提供服務的 好了吧
什麼服務
就是那些
合約男友
你出來賣
隨便 怎麼說都是一句
為什麼又是我
是因為我蠢嗎
你不要說出來
蠢人好 蠢人多快樂
你要的錢我幫你籌夠了 你要騙就騙吧
我不是騙 我是收費的
拜託你
不要總是想著吃霸王餐 好嗎
其實你從來不覺得
我做演員會成功的 是嗎
你會成功的 你是最棒的
你再給我錢 我再繼續說
說多少遍都可以的
你別哭 她會懷疑我的
你別打爛我飯碗
表姐都叫你不要吸毒
會害死你
回頭是岸 表姐
謝謝
你演戲就演戲 別打我
我又不是表姐
對不起 我不是故意
你換一下角色 演被騙的那個可以嗎
好
你出來賣
隨便 怎麼說都是一句
你為什麼出來賣
你別哭
她會懷疑我
你長得像個弱智 憑什麼出來賣
你說我什麼都可以
請你不要說我是弱智
這個根本不是一個事實
說中了你的死穴
你肯定從小就被人當作弱智
所以你才到處騙人找自信
胡說八道 我從小就人見人愛
他們不是愛你 是可憐你
你閉嘴
像你這種人這輩子都不配得到愛
我
人見人愛 人見人愛
這樣醜
打爆你
你為什麼老這樣
對不起
我真的不是故意
好 夠了 下一個
對不起 對不起
喂
這邊啊
你入圍了
你們在做什麼
我們來找女兒
找女兒請到警察局 不是到這裡的
- 那邊上 - 謝謝
那邊
剛剛聽完這首歌 我內心真是百感交集
不知道大家是否也感同身受
- 在那裡 - 好 接下來我們繼續頒獎
今年最佳女主角的競爭真的非常激烈
在這個入圍名單裡
真是集結了當今華語電影圈
老中青三代的實力派女演員
那麼究竟花落誰家呢
在揭曉之前
一起看看她們成名前的珍貴片段
林允以前原來挺漂亮
是
這又是誰
什麼啊 是小夢
對
有請頒獎嘉賓
很榮幸可以在今晚頒發這個獎項
獲得最佳女主角的是
這位演員真的是從電影誕生以來
直到宇宙滅亡都難得一見
你別那麼多廢話
人生啊
就是兩個字
如夢
就是你 就是你
恭喜
夢姐
如夢 如夢
沒關係 沒關係
夢姐 你好
我是你的粉絲
我很喜歡看你的電影
謝謝
其實我也是個演員 你覺得我有機會嗎
你真喜歡表演
我天生就是為了表演 我行嗎
你不行
從現在到宇宙滅亡 你都沒機會
明白嗎
明白
那你現在打算怎麼辦
我只能回家耕作
當然不可以
你不要管我說什麼
繼續努力
你會成功的
我知道了 謝謝